Elon Musk bought us out to make a tiny
village for his workers Elon Musk has
spent Millions purchasing land in a
small Texas neighborhood in Bastrop
outside of Austin City Limits to build
his own little village near Tesla SpaceX
and boring companies musk's vision is to
create his own Utopia where his
employees can live and work some of the
locals have already sold their land to
musk but while they were initially told
it would be the use for workers housing
they learned later that musk plan to
build a town however must call The Wall
Street Journal report that he is
building a town false on Friday the idea
of living in an unregulated private town
or city has risen in popularity in
recent years and Praxis is one of the
newer projects funded partially by Peter
Thiel the goal is to build a city
outside the United States and free of
government control there's interest for
that I have a question for you go ahead
anytime you use that sarcastic slow
voice you have a strong opinion on
something like that so tell me Patrick
why did you read it in that tone what
are you feeling like this you know I I
just like that he's toying with people
I love it I love the fact that he's
toying with people and messing with
people and just getting them to
constantly talk about what he's up to
but by the way if he's doing this what's
wrong with it say he is doing this and
say you work for Tesla and say you asked
for it you know we have some guys here
that you know we were about to made that
offer on that 11 acre land that we were
looking at you know what a lot of people
ask for can we build some boxable homes
there yeah can we get five or ten
boxable homes where we can rent the idea
of wanting to build a community is not
far-fetched or anything there's a lot of
other people that wish
that wish they had the kind of a culture
where the people would want to build a
community yeah that's called you're
making great cultures Now by force it's
by choice you don't have to live there
it's purely a choice and a benefit and
an adult so whether he's doing this or
whether he's not doing this there's no
difference between what he is doing but
what Disney World did in Orlando when
Walt Disney was using other people's
names to buy a plan because they didn't
want to sell it to him directly and then
all of a sudden they're like holy
this guy bought up all the land and he
built his own ZIP code or two or three
called Disney World elon's just building
his own Disney World shout out to him by
the way I'm all about the company
culture and when you were gonna maybe
make that 13 million dollar offer on
that 40 million dollar condo in downtown
Miami at the Thousand Biscayne Museum
the Hadid building I was willing to
sacrifice my lifestyle to live in that
ridiculous Penthouse Universe
patriotic from your end so if that's
what you want to build if you want to
build that community that small village
in down downtown Miami and you need a
tough team leader yeah just sign me up
me up to the
you're like a great uh uh War buddy
willing to go above and beyond and
sacrifice yourself I was just gonna say
it comes down to sacrifice Pat and I'm
willing to sacrifice what I'm doing
right now it's an emotional to live in
the penthouse
right now so I think it comes down
ChapStick and you are kissing some major
butt at the moment nah he he by the way
he knows how much I love Heights and the
balcony like what I would do is every
night we'd have dinner in the balcony
that's what we would be doing every
night so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]